Katie Holmes and Suri Cruise enjoy a  night of basketball I was really excited  the adorable mommy daughter duo attended  the Lakers Detroit Pistons basketball  game at the Staples Center in LA Sunday  night and the two were all smiles  laughing and having a great time  courtside Katy's ten-year-old daughter  looked too cute in an all pink ensemble  her look included a pink floral dress  along with a matching sweater and bow  she's a sophisticated little girl while  her mama looked equally gorgeous and a  navy blue lace top and jeans Katy opened  up to et in October about her special  bond with Suri because she makes every  day great and awesome and and better and  I know myself more because of her  you